in the meantime you've heard this move
and he he did touch on it here Lucas
this idea can uh the governor do what
he's been doing in Texas that is using
law enforcement for example to arrest
migrants and even judges in the state to
deport them uh the administration is
suing Texas uh as it tries to do that
Brad Co is a Kenny County Texas Sheriff
uh Brad Co I should say Sheriff always
good to see you what did you make of
this move on the part of the White House
to sue the governor Texas more
specifically uh about using you know
guys like you to to arrest
migrants Good Morning Neil uh I think
the governor's got it the plan is
workable if the federal government won't
protect our Southern border it's up to
the governor to do it and he has he
drawn that Line in the Sand and I'm
going to stand right here beside him as
he does that so this is going to go back
and forth in the courts and I see a lot
of legal battles here I don't see much
progress being made on dealing with the
root of the problem which is the Border
itself what what do you think happens
well like you just said it's going to be
legal battle back and forth they're just
trying to deflect exactly what's going
on down here at the border the root
cause I really can't tell you I know
that there's some economic issues and
there's there's things like that all
around the world but what's causing it
is the fact that just before he took
office he said he would have an open
border come see me here we are you're
welcome and they're taking advantage of
that you know when you say they're
taking advantage of a tri one thing I
don't understand is when they aren
processed often times we'll go to Eagle
Pass some of the other places where we
have drones sometimes running live
around the clock you see you know a few
hundred one day you could see thousands
another day I'm just wondering where did
those migrants
go well after they after they get on
process they put them on the bus and
from here they're headed to San Antonia
where they're dispersed throughout the
country from there so no one is
necessarily keeping track of
them no uh they're given we've seen
documents where they're supposed to have
a court date as far away as as
2031 and an 8year period they're not
going to show up for that court date 90%
of I feel are just going to assimilate
into the country and and live in the
shadows so when you see the fights that
erupt even among you know Sanctuary
cities and states like New York and New
Jersey right now they're having this
back and forth over who's going to house
them uh in the end uh neither wants
anything to do with them so what is that
make you think of the sanctuary status
that these states and cities brag about
well yeah like just said they brag about
we're we're a sanctuary City come here
we'll take care of you well now that the
people are showing up and being
transported out there on their on the
own free will traveling across the
country like our constitution gives the
right to now they don't want to deal
with them but they expect us to deal
with them down here on the southern
Border in the meantime you guys are
swamped as it is so this added burden
and you don't look at as a burden you'll
try to do that you know to arrest them
or deal with them yourself uh they only
so many men and women you have right
sure that's right I've got six full-time
deputies and six part-time deputies and
we're seeing record numbers every year
because of this our Pursuits last year
long we had over 260 Pursuits through my
County when you say a Pursuit when you
you're chasing someone that that that's
the essence of that right and that's
dangerous in and of itself we're all
involved yes sir I mean we had one last
year where we were pursuing the
individual in in an effort to get away
he started shooting at oncoming traffic
leaning out the window with pistol
shooting an oncoming traffic that the
truck that he hit happened to be one of
our locals she was one of our school
teachers I've known this girl since
before she was born I worked with her
father for 30 years and her her brother
is one of my deputies so at that point
in time this became extremely
personal just amazing um Sheriff good
luck handling the fight uh it's a crazy
fight at that and you've been thrust
into it but you handle it with with the
you know with ease but I don't know how
you do it uh Brad Co the Kenny County
Texas Sheriff I'm Steve duy I'm Brian
kilme and I'm Angley aart and click here
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling
analysis